for pricing information and to request a
tape William Triplett and Edward
Timberlake wrote bread dragon rising
about China's military threat to America
their book criticizes the Clinton
administration for its policies towards
China which the authors argue is trying
to dominate the Pacific region they
appeared on a call-in radio program
Janet partials America earlier this
month
welcome to jannecke partials America I'm
Janet Parshall broadcasting from the
nation's capital so good to have you
with me my friends I tell you what some
guys like WC Fields I would rather be in
Philadelphia and today is one of them we
are pushing aside all news except the
news the most important news of the day
we talked frequently on this program
about China
and about our bizarre foreign policy
with the Communist Chinese and we are so
thankful that there are wonderful folks
out there who declare the truth even if
it isn't going to be reported in some of
the general press folks like Ed
Timberlake and Bill Triplett who are no
stranger to our audience they've been
here before it every time they come our
phones go absolutely crazy and again
proving once again that God is my
executive producer today's front page of
the Washington Times reads China targets
Taiwan with second missile base and it's
subtitled can now hit all major military
posts on island 10th agon says that news
for you well there's a whole lot more
coming your way let me introduce my
guests we'll give the phone number and
then we'll get right into the brand new
book that these gentlemen have again
co-authored at Timberlake is a Naval
Academy graduate with an MBA from
Cornell has served as a Marine Corps
fighter pilot as a professional staffer
in Congress and in the Defense
Department he now serves on the board of
the Vietnam Children's Fund a pro bono
effort to rebuild elementary schools in
Vietnam and he lives in gorgeous
Annapolis Maryland bill Triplett the
second is the former chief republican
counsel to the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee he has more than 30 years of
experience working on China and national
security and he and his family lived the
beautiful live near the beautiful city
of Annapolis
together they have co-authored a
brand-new book entitled red dragon
rising communist China's military threat
to America and in bill what an honor to
have you both with us thanks for joining
us all thanks a lot this is always great
opinion well I tell you what I learned
so much but I will be honest with you
when we're done I have a headaches this
big with all the information that you've
given me believe me we did not plan this
that today this book which again is
published by our dear friends at Regnery
is out today and the headline of the
Washington Times China targets Taiwan
with second missile base you to have a
crystal ball you keep somewhere and you
look and do it on a regular basis well
the sort of this is Bill talking and
thank you for having us again but the
sort of joke is we
pay the Chinese military to do something
bad about every 72 hours so we can
continue to have material for the book
but as a practical matter you're dealing
with a Chinese communist military that
is rising that has stolen all sorts of
technologies from us and has what I
would describe as non benign interests
and aims in the Far East and it's it is
definitely getting tough ever tougher
every day out in the Far East there's no
question about it before you respond it
because that you said something very
significant you said none benign now if
you use that in a medical thing it means
you've got something deadly going on
here what do you mean by non benign well
I'm gonna pass half of this to add
because he knows that better than I do
but for example on Christmas Day that
Chinese are going to take delivery of a
ship from the Russians that was designed
only to kill Americans Merry Christmas
yeah Merry Christmas Prince of Peace in
fact we have a picture of it from page
167 I'm looking for it right now now go
ahead well the ship I think was a
transfer intentionally on Christmas Day
I think it was a studied insult
it's a supermini destroyer designed and
delayed fading days of the Soviet empire
with only one mission which is to go out
and shoot and die if you'll notice in
the picture there are eight tubes you
see four on each side there tubes
containing what they call sunburn that's
the NATO code word for the missile it
comes in two two and a half times the
speed of sound goes out about 80 miles
does a pop-up maneuver that you can't
defend against but really when you even
consider trying to defend against it it
may be an exercise in futility because
it's nuclear-tipped this ship can kill
the seventh Fleet the Russians have
announced in a rapprochement with China
that they're going to start joint combat
training next year and they're gonna get
another silver many and perhaps a couple
more on order the Chinese government has
not spend money ill-advised and they
really wanted this ship this ship is
part of their overall plan I believe to
fence off Taiwan so they can then
basically go up against Taiwan playing
right into your headline Thanks so the
whole thing is coming together the
Chinese government is very clever in
which
built their military and they're
modernizing quickly and we're going to
be rudely awakened in the Pacific rather
quickly I believe that with all of my
heart now let me do this I could be very
selfish I'm not going to I want to open
the phone lines and give you an
opportunity to interact with Bill and Ed
some of the most eloquent apologists on
what's going on with the Communist
Chinese and it's a wake up call not
necessarily happy news but absolutely
necessary news 1-800 three four three
nine two eight two is our number one
eight hundred three four three nine two
eight two and again my thanks to our
dear friends at Regnery I've got some
copies of this book to give away and I'm
also going to tell you how you can get
it less the 20% they always offer us
when we have these great Regnery authors
on one eight hundred three four three
nine two eight two gentlemen you see
Christmas the lights beginning to go on
all of a sudden let me go back with what
you just said in this this very
disconcerting photo of this ship let me
go to the headline shine at targets
Taiwan with second missile base I
believe strongly in building a platform
of information three-minute packages at
the end of the day are not enough to get
substantive information for folks who
can't even find Taiwan on a map they
have not yet discovered why this is
going to be what we call the tiebreaker
in America Chinese dialogue why is this
so significant well the reason it's
significant is because Taiwan is a
democracy and the mainland of China is
not and if you allow twenty two million
people in a democracy to be conquered
and that's what we're talking about
right here just like Hitler attacked
Poland the same thing if you allow them
to be conquered that means that everyone
else who are our friends and allies
overseas begin to wonder if maybe
they're on the wrong side and so you can
see people in Japan people in Europe
people even in Latin America begin to
wonder and that's why it's so important
that you should not allow a democracy I
mean leaving aside the fact that I know
lots of Chinese people who live on
Taiwan and they're friends of mine and
so forth and so on and I don't want
horrible things to happen to them from a
pure political science standpoint you
don't want a democracy to be conquered
well especially if we are the leading
democracy on the planet that there would
be a philosophical and moral
underpinning for the
exactly that takes me maybe you can
respond to this to what I think is the
most problematic aspect of this
administration and there are many but
there have been problems with the
morality of this administration from day
one but especially when we see that it's
application to foreign diplomacy because
his declarative statement is we quote
suspend moral judgment well wait a
minute you either support the ideals and
ideas of a democracy or you abandon them
it is not an eighth moral decision we'll
be right back after this stay with us hi
this is Janet Parshall and we're in a
commercial break right now and I'd like
to thank you so very much for calling I
want to point out to you that if you
were on the phone line you would be on
nine and ten so every line is Li just
like that that's the max that we can
take right now and they're all lips
interesting and I want to talk also
about the the philosophy that says that
we don't have to worry about China about
an economic nation that they're so far
behind that it's gonna take them forever
to get caught up and it sounded very
signifying nothing
Janet will point out is this picture yes
is breaking news this was never ever
seen in America till we put it on the
book cover it's Bill Clinton in the Oval
Office I'll save this for the air
because Oakland in the Oval Office with
the commanding general of China
you took our character and human rights
this is exactly the wrong message to be
sending the Chinese dissidents you want
to pray in China you want to get on the
internet in China you want to be free
and you see something like this which
they put from border to border in the
PRC the the message is give it up this
guy is who supposed to stand up for the
Constitution is sitting there at cozy
with the Chinese the Chinese we have
something going and that is I have sons
in the toilet in their 20s he has
daughters in their 20s so they were the
same ages as the young people who are
killed and I've interviewed I've been to
Tiananmen Square after the event I have
interviewed all sorts of people and
they've told me how they're cut their
classmates were shot beside them and so
forth and so on and this guy can't even
take the Nuremberg defense that I was
following orders he gave the orders
oh mercy this is all done in secret you
as a journalist cannot obtain this pick
from the White House you can't obtain
any of the other pictures from the White
House because they won't really they
won't release and six to the seven
generals who participated in the
massacre have all elevated all in secret
have been hosted by this administration
we have picture leavings of famous
pictures out this guy arrived the week
of the Monica Lewinsky report and
they're bringing back the spymaster that
ran the operation the commanding general
he's supposed to come into the country
this month or next or next they wait
while Congress is out session we felt
the moral obligation to show those but
you know what when I went through these
I thought I'm glad you did because this
isn't a philosophical debate there's
flesh-and-blood time we've chopped you
down and I can tell you my wife the
doctor the pediatrician came down though
I was yes and no on alternate days we
came to the conclusion that because this
is secret if we didn't show exact we
would be a kind of enabler if you will
if you didn't understand why this guy is
bad I mean there's a there's a little
girl in the top picture in this one
barely make yeah well you can make out
her shoe yeah I talked to my daughters
and they said go ahead dad put it in but
but it but he it was it was the last
decision we made whether to put the
pictures in or not and as you know we
dedicated the book to them yes right it
was precious this was tough and then
this is not you know you don't write a
book and say I hope you enjoyed them
know exactly in fact you know as I was
going through this I thought to myself
maybe it's just me having gone through
the 60s and my kids are exactly the same
age this is yours
I'm thinking this is deja vu all over
again like yogi said I thought we had
had the big discussion about communism
and what happens is the rears its head
again and we don't recognize it for what
it is or we choose to look the other way
when it first they killed the kids and
then of course what happens is kids
didn't come home at night parents come
to the edge of the square they soothe
the parents and then they shoot the
doctors nurses
well I knew this would happen when Ed
Timberlake and Bill Triplett come and
they talk about China it always catches
your attention and for that I'm very
happy every single line is lit I'm gonna
go to the phones in a minute but I was
asking a question that I think I think
I'm gonna believe this on the heart of a
whole lot of you as well and that is we
have an administration just to recap
again we have an administration that
practices a kind of worldview that says
that it will suspend moral judgment a
democracy is not a moral a democracy is
a strong moral position we believe an
individual responsibility we believe an
individual freedom we have fought for
that you and I can get in the car we can
drive down here two blocks to Arlington
Cemetery and we can see the men and
women who gave their lives for that
cause you cannot suspend moral judgment
with a government that is totalitarian
and crushes the lifeblood out of its own
people and puts our country at risk
forgive me for the simplicity of this
question but are we so enamored with
greed we are willing to sacrifice
principle well as an investigator on the
hill oftentimes I felt this
gravitational force pulling us away and
it had a lot to do with the issue of
trade and the argument always thrown at
bill and I are well look please look at
the model free enterprise makes people
free if I thought that was true I'd make
that argument thank you but we see the
exact opposite effect we were talking
about the poor kids murdered in
Tiananmen massacred well now what we
find we find I don't know much about it
but just seems to be really what it is
Falun Gong is meditation and breathing
exercises and they're dragging
grandmothers out of Tiananmen Square for
doing breathing exercises they just shut
down if you read the Foreign Press 200
newspapers in mainland China you want to
pray in China and you go to the wrong
Catholic Church which happens to be a
charade the government sets up you're in
the fear you're really not in the
Catholic Church they're trying to pull
out the underground church so they could
really take them down
they're definitely afraid of their own
people we really believe that China
could implode we hope that's the case
but you know what they studied how we
did solidarity and we took down the
Soviet empire we really did with
communications and the Pope and things
like that and they don't want to catch
the quote polish disease
they learned very cleverly how to take
all these communication devices which we
can argue maybe to make the villagers
free but instead they route them through
the People's Armed Police so they can
track their citizens it's a really big
brother over there now I have a million
questions and I don't want to be selfish
because we've got all kinds of folks
online but I talked about communication
bring us up to speed on this latest
declarative statement coming out of
communist China that talks about using
the internet that is amazing to me well
the Internet of course is a way that in
fact people can't communicate but what
happens when the people controlling the
Internet happened to be a major-general
and the Chinese army that we wrote a
previous book which we talked about
before called a year the rat and in it
we went through the Laurel and Hughes
business and described it and you find
that the gateways are controlled by the
Chinese army in many cases or the
Chinese police so how are you going to
become free when brig brother is
controlling the means of communication
exactly exactly
now let and I don't want to digress but
I must throw this out because we are
sitting here just days away from the
handover of the Panama Canal this is
another amazing situation to me dr.
Thomas cabal was a guest on our show
earlier this week went up testified
before the House Banking Committee
talked about Chinese money laundering
we've got Helen Chenoweth now has
introduced the House Joint Resolution 77
saying no that didn't count that treaty
didn't count we need to go back and
re-examine it again you've got the
establishment of nuclear submarines that
can go after us we've got Taiwan the
tension building up their second missile
base we've got these barbaric human
rights and now we've got them in our
backyard in our backyard with the Panama
Canal that's right and I and to be fair
a lot of people have looked at this and
have done a very good job in describing
it I wouldn't say that we have a lot to
offer to the Panama Canal however if you
look at the Panama Canal and you look at
the Long Beach business with Costco ok
and if you look in here where we talk
about how they're moving into Cuba I
think you can find a pattern a fine hand
here in fact
interestingly enough the Turks have told
us that the Chinese military is moving
into a place called the Dardanelles and
for those who know their geography
that's the choke point between the Black
Sea and the Mediterranean and it's
Chinese military companies and they're
moving into places that make no
commercial sense and the Turks ask us
what are these guys doing there and we
think there may be some very long-term
plan and again not benign mercy let me
go to the phones 800 3 4 3 9 - 8 -
that's our number 1 800 3 4 3 9 - 8 -
let me go to Ed first in Atlanta Georgia
listening on WN IV ed welcome thank you
you're welcome
I have a two-part question one sort of
relates to what you were talking about a
few minutes ago regarding the the loss
of of our nuclear secrets and so forth
what is in place to bring the people
that involved even though it you know
let's say if it's a Al Gore or you know
even the president and whatever you know
the Clinton you know just I can't I
cannot understand how we people could
basically risk the national sovereignty
of this country or even out you know our
lives really and that it just appalled
me that that this is have that this has
happened the other question is is there
any way that maybe we could counteract
this this vessel that has been developed
and you know even as far as maybe making
a first strike against it or something
well yes sir thank you for your question
I if I understood the first part of it
it's the question what happened how did
they get away with it what's going on in
that area
well we wrote you're the rat as a
bribery book I think we make the
definitive case we've interviewed all a
lot of the senior people as a hill
investigator I asked a lot of questions
of the State Department the Commerce
Department the Energy Department
Department of Defense and we found
across the board that we were not
getting forthcoming answers at all from
the executive Carter at the highest
levels in fact it was dissembling to the
point where I'm almost gonna say lies
and in one area it was very striking the
State Department identified a person
named Lou Cho yang-ho tallying Lou as a
northern Chinese entrepreneur when I
talked to Johnny Chong it turns out and
we found this out she's Lieutenant
Colonel Lou military operative or the
People's Republic of China and we in the
Rules Committee of staff trying to
advance the case we're stalled for a
couple months to try and figure out
exactly what we're dealing with the
second question is we tend not to shoot
first that's the problem with this
over-many it can be taken out as an f4
pilot I could sink it probably my
airplane enough in a few was any rockets
if I had to but the point is they
probably if they do it right can either
deter us get us out of the way or shoot
first if they shoot first we're gone the
problem we have is that you can't
preempt it's not the nature of the way
we do military operations this is bill I
was on on board this kind of a ship two
years ago and in fact in the book the
picture of the ship is mine
the interesting thing is this is an
offensive platform it's not designed
like Western ships are to take a hit and
keep fighting it's there to shoot or
dock and one
of those missiles has 20 times the power
of Hiroshima oh wow
take out the whole fleet all the
American sailors and marines would be
killed you know and again you have to
drop this into context because context
is everything we do an awful lot of
programs here on our armed forces and on
the military and we've got a president
who's been anti-military sure who has
defunded it who has continued to cut
funding who wants to use the military if
you will as a sociological petri dish
and try all sorts of radical things from
women in combat to gays in the military
and in the meantime we have real enemies
so when and if there's some sort of a
strike wherever it comes from and this
is a philosophical question but it's
also a practical one are we gonna be
ready well yesterday was Pearl Harbor
day exactly and I'm very concerned now
because one the ship is obviously an
issue the second thing though our allies
may believe we're not ready because the
headline in The Washington Times you're
breaking news right now we picked up
over the Asian press that the vice
president of Taiwan basically is saying
they may have to develop their own force
no that is significant this is about
nuclear force you make nuclear force
right once once they believe America by
Blink and this President may blink then
Japan has to cut its own deal they may
go nuclear or they may start paying off
South Korea becomes general the
Philippine Islands have the Spratlys
that they're gonna lose through the
Chinese government thousand miles off
the coast with China but most
importantly also Taiwan the other oddly
thing about the People's Republic of
China is they sell all this stuff to
Iran Iraq Syria Libya Cuba they're
operating with pretty thug ish people
for money and we have a very nasty
adversary out there across the board and
unfortunately and tragically except for
Governor Bush's speech what I thought
was very very good on this subject this
hasn't really risen to the level of
awareness so the American family can
wake up in the morning and say my god
what's going to happen our kids going to
be called to serve we have to have this
debate we lose we have to have the
debate salutely absolutely that's right
well I mean when I say all of those
sailors and Marines would be killed
we're talking someone's husband
someone's wife these days someone's
nephew someone
son daughter whatever this is real this
is real now the whole [ __ ] crowd of
course they don't have anybody who
serves and so it wouldn't be them but
nonetheless we're talking about a real
opponent nuclear-powered and I mean
nuclear-armed and I'm going to raise the
ante substantially on christmas-day
point and thank you very much we're
gonna give you a copy of the brand-new
books that my guests have written by the
way if you haven't gotten your the rat
you need to get it but they're brand new
one is red dragon rising and we're gonna
give you a copy of it and I appreciate
it let me go to Dallas Texas now where
Eric joins us listening on KW Rd using a
cell phone how are you Eric what what
can we do to confront this I mean how do
we affect the policymakers back yes and
build on Eric for a minute I hear this
every day here there is a sense of
disenfranchisement this is the
quintessential David and Goliath battle
I'm just a taxpayer I'm taking good care
of my family
we're talking about huge monolithic
governments with very powerful weapons I
can't do anything actually you can you
can beat them and in fact the only way
to beat them is from the bottom up it
isn't gonna happen from the top down and
the best example of this clearly is
Costco attempting to get into Long Beach
California
the people in California discovered this
they discovered that their own officials
were on the wrong side so they went to a
senator in the middle of the country
from Oklahoma and they got him and get
engaged because he's a patriot you can
do this if you are organized if you are
determined you can beat them but it has
to come from the bottom it cannot come
from the top and the other thing yeah
it's really important get all the
candidates for the presidents here on
record yes all candidates by the way
four House and Senate two because when
the time of testing comes you want to
know where they stood excellent point
EDI Lake bill Triplett are my guest
their brand-new book published by
Regnery is entitled red dragon rising
communist China's military threat to
America trust me they wrote the book
before today's headlines but it speaks
with the eloquence with which they
address this issue Eric don't go away
we're gonna give you a copy of it we're
gonna take as many of your calls as you
can at eight hundred three four three
nine two eight two also get a pencil and
paper will give you a number for Regnery
and how you can get the book for 20% off
don't go away
you haven't heard anything yet we'll be
back
[Music]
I catch the essence of this question yes
you shoot it perfectly perfectly and I'm
so glad he did that and I purposely went
to him while it might not be the most
profound substantively it is the heart
cry if so many Americans going golly if
you can't do this in Washington what am
I supposed to do well if it wasn't for
you and CMS and Fox and America's
employees
we're totally out of business on this
well you two have to be suffering the
slings and arrows of a whole lot of
criticism because I had Bill Gertz on
yesterday when he reported this story he
said Beijing went berserk saying that's
a poppycock that's enough any true at
all well you two must get the same thing
anyways or basis to all the time we also
get the trade people trying to get ours
are keeping us out of the way
minimize that oh I'm a China scholar and
also my many of the China scholars who
feel they have to tell Beijing's line in
order to keep getting visa it's the
exactly we have that problem there's an
express the Chinese Communists know how
to play the extortion game and so they
they play this against American
corporations they guess the academics
and against the press people you never
see a hot China story being broken in
Beijing it's always broken here and the
reason is because the reporters know
that they would get named persona
non-grata and know they're very very
good at what they do and I take nothing
very good they dangle trade in front of
the American corporations I was in
Shanghai doll and a boy are they getting
skunked there was one case where a
building was stolen they designed a
building they gave it to the People's
Council they said well we'll give to
this smaller Council and they said you
didn't ask monster Oh
six months later they're walking down
there's a building was the major
construction firm there but the problem
is the importers the people with the
markups right they're the ones that love
it you know you take a sneaker and you
multiply by ten but what's amazing to me
again first of all the whole philosophy
of introduced people to free enterprise
and they'll be free give me the one
historical example where you see that
prove it show it to me and agree we
don't see it and number two if you're
just a cold numbers cruncher the deficit
goes through the roof
how are people being benefited as a
result of this trade oration
relationship it does
make any sense today no it's this yes
thank you no it's doing real good thank
you very much I appreciate it you know
Dennis we do join forces ironically
there are honest uh liberals out there a
few but the human rights people are 100%
exact right down the line labor unions
are very good on it too
yeah worried about their throats being
cut there isn't an interesting you know
that when we we had a press conference
at the Family Resource Council on this
and I sat back and just had the warmest
feeling cuz I looked at the most
eclectic coalition of people I'd ever
seen in my life but I thought that's how
this work gets done is you do have this
this eclectic gathering together of all
kinds of people but the problem is you
would think even if you let doing this
kind of stuff you'd see this group in
you go oh that's probably not a voting
group that isn't represented somewhere
and you do the right thing it is this
arrogance where it's just an abandonment
of even when all the groups together
things
yeah it's truly yours what do you give
hope for is it they may not be able
control the Internet as much as anything
oh really oh yeah yeah I have a little
bit of hope there's that you pick a
fight with the internet crowd infiltrate
penetrate China and maybe just maybe we
get the message out but they're working
diligently to do it I mean they are
really worried about the internet isn't
it amazing
yeah and of course they're using
information warfare against the Falun
Gong yes exactly and they trace some of
the addresses back in whose's to go to
that secret police who should be
surprised
oh yes yes exactly you know I was
watching Chinese television when they
did the first round of a Falun Gong and
they said you know any sort of religious
belief whatsoever is antithetical to
socialist view therefore we're gonna
wipe it out and I thought look one
doesn't have to be a subscriber to Falun
Gong to understand that it's them today
it's the Catholics tomorrow it's whoever
exactly they're they're very it's it's a
tragedy of epic proportions and if we
had right policy I think we can make
China free I agree and that won't
imagine a free child RT that would sort
of radically redefined the whole world
but leading national security issues
facing
I'll free China
if you'd like to order a cassette copy
of today's program please mention
today's date and send $5 to Janet
partials America 1901 North Moore Street
mor e street suite 200 arlington
virginia - 2 to 0-9 and if you'd like to
fax Janet partials America it's seven
zero three eight oh seven two two five
zero and thanks for listening
and if you just joined us boy did you
miss a first half hour but don't go away
cuz there's a whole lot more coming now
in this second half my guests are with
me in studio today what a treat
red dragon rising is that book you
remember them as the co-authors of year
of the rat every time we have had f
timberlake and bill tripling on our
phones go crazy because i sense sitting
in front of a microphone every day that
there's a real hunger for this
information and it's simply just not
getting out there and when you hear it
you respond and that doesn't surprise me
my thanks also to Regnery publishing for
being bold enough to publish these kinds
of books let me tell you how you can get
a copy of red dragon rising we have a
great relationship with them if you call
one eight eight eight two one nine four
seven four seven that's one eight eight
eight two one nine four seven four seven
say that you heard ed and bill here on
Janet partials America and those great
folks take twenty percent right off the
cost of the book and throw in shipping
and handling for free and I'm also gonna
give you this morning don't read this
before bed sleep it'll keep you up I
said that live here at the rat it'll get
you mad but it'll call you to action and
that is their real agenda that you and I
respond that we look well to America and
we can't afford to sleep this one out so
one eight and eight two one nine four
seven four seven telling me her dead and
Bill right here on Janet partials
America they'll take twenty percent off
gentlemen you see every line is lit but
you have to talk about the photo on the
front this is amazing to me it is the
interesting thing is this photo right
here shows the Chinese general named
Kerr with President Clinton in the Oval
Office this is in essence a kind of
secret photo because you can't you as a
journalist cannot obtain this this
photograph in fact to be honest I tried
to get the Washington Post and the NBC
to get it they tried they couldn't we
had
get it overseas but this photo shows up
on the front page of all of the major
newspapers in China and and what it does
is it demoralizes the the Chinese dove
democracy movement because think of how
hard it is every day to make China free
when you have to deal with the secret
police and the army and all of this kind
of thing and then on the front page of
the newspaper you have the president of
the free world
together with a major killer and now why
am i calling him a major killer I'm
calling him a major killer because he is
the one who gave the orders to kill the
young people at Tiananmen Square he
cannot say well I was just following
orders he gave the orders and he is
never apologized for that
and he owes his position and power and
so forth but because he was ready to
kill Chinese young people and we
dedicate the book to the Fallen at
Tiananmen Square and if you were saying
something earlier that it isn't just
this man but how many others have been
set it at the White House we found the
clinton ministration is hosted by our
count six to the seven generals we have
another food measure you get two more
pictures one of the president the Oval
Office and one of them the head spy guys
that ran the operational overlooking the
shoulder of the Secretary of Defense we
thought that was a clever kind of
looking in there what happens is that
they bring them in they revolt ate them
in a lot of ways because it's it's
sanctifying them as you know being
representatives that are worthy of our
attendance you know with the President
and that's wrong you know we have a
constitution we stand for democracy and
and these are the antistick all
individuals to a democratic feeling
movement they're the ones that really
brought the troops in and in Tiananmen
we found that not only did the machine
gun the kids and use flamethrowers to
burn the bodies it's I'm sorry to talk
this harsh but when the parents came to
identify the bodies they shot the
parents oh and then when the kids
crawled or carried to the aid stations
they broke in a machine gun the doctors
and nurses this is what they were
capable of doing right see what happened
is Tiananmen Square happened mostly at
night and and of course the kids who
were killed or wounded didn't come home
so the parents get worried they come to
the edge of the square because it was
carted off at the time
and the parents got machine gun right in
front of one of the major hotels and
while it that the parents are lying in
pools of blood or for wounded ambulances
come up and the doctors and nurses are
dressed in white in China and get out of
them out of the ambient ambulances and
they were shot down right there by the
by this guy's troops and so I mean if
they're willing to do that
they're obviously willing they have no
problem with always killing us that's
that's exactly that's why and in fact we
were talking during a break on why you
include some pictures of the massacre
and you both said you struggled you went
back and forth that's right but I think
first of all I want to tell you as
unpleasant as they're I think that we
had to see them so we understand this is
not a philosophical debate this is a
very real and debate that's right and
one of the most amazing pictures happens
to be a picture of bodies that had been
rolled over by the tanks just absolutely
unbelievable
let me if I can gentlemen take a break
friends I will not be selfish I will
come back and go right to the phones
with our guest bill Triplett and then
Timberlake a whole lot more coming your
way stay with us your callers have a
particularly good reputation and
deservedly and being knowledgeable and
caring and so forth and so on you
probably don't remember but I was on
with you a with year of the rat and lady
came on and said I don't have a question
I just want to talk about you're in the
rat and I was astounded at how and what
she was and I said to her hey we should
have had you as our Edit exactly but we
do like coming on your show I resent
that with well I know that people are
hungry for this look it was no crowding
whatsoever we say goodbye to a caller
boom that got immediately replaced
there's a hunger in the human heart for
this you know again back to the pictures
whether we show the pictures upon c-span
or not I don't know it's a it's your
call
they're horrible I mean they were taken
by a Chinese Patriot if you look in here
there's no there's no caption this
person
nameless right forever because he'd be
killed and so we have to keep we have to
keep that you know private but we didn't
want to become enablers to this process
that's going on exactly
see this is half of the problem you the
first half of the problem is the is the
moral side the the political side or the
for the democratic movement the second
half which is EDS half yes after this
guy leaves he then goes and and goes
through all the military installation we
have a black-and-white picture of him at
los alamos but not in his uniform
unfortunately was not good enough to be
reproduced so so where do they go with
this they go and get the memory they go
to the top they go to the top time they
go to Edwards Air Force Base they go to
Luke Air Force Base they get access to
these play yes I'm a graduate of the
senior officers course the top end
didn't fly their senior officer breathe
out squadron C of a fighter squadron and
I call out there and got stonewalled
until I talk to Duke Cunningham who
still flies yes I used to fly us do can
beat me every time it's so capable doing
it he's better than I am 100% yeah right
and you walk into his office and it's
airplanes ever yeah he was livid they
think everything's are the same tactics
everything and those taxes are taxes we
were really developing people dying in
Mike squad roommates paid the price
we've got practice exactly to show them
that stuff is giving away our ultimate
that's to the enemy exactly actually
that I can understand I can in in our
our equipment and our tactics become our
allies equipment
what does Israel fly we have 15 and the
f16 whose tactics do they use yeah some
of their own actually not from us they
teach us we're giving away essentially
our edge becomes their edge because we
are the leaders of the Democratic
Alliance and this is true for Japanese
pilots or Taiwan pilots or you know
we're giving it all the way see and I'm
a white person I've shared that with you
before I want to dig to sources and I
want to find out and we'll cut it off at
the root not at the time I don't want to
ask this because this is what a caller
is gonna ask you to and that is why
why do we do is it all trade funny
when they tell you it's not money you
know exactly exactly
I'm out by saying Bill Clinton and Al
Gore took the money and ran and that's
what we believe
mercy you know we haven't even gotten
into drugs and thugs yeah exactly
let's put drugs and thugs off to it
we'll do a different skill on that one
exactly well especially with today oh
okay
it's just amazing to me you know I think
of the scripture that says the love of
money is the root of all evil and the
older I get the more I realized money is
not the problem it's where the heart is
connected with money and we're willing
to sell it all it's just amazing to me
it's its power and greed oh isn't it oh
my word
intertwine
[Music]
[Music]
I want to go right to the phones because
so many of you have questions for our
guest bill Triplett and edit Timberlake
and again their brand-new book you've
got to get your the rap that's the first
one they co-authored this one now is
entitled red dragon rising communist
China's military threat to America Tommy
you've got a great question you're in
Leesburg Virginia listening on wav a on
a copy of your the rat already and I
found it more disturbing than
entertaining this of course but I have a
comment I would like some of an opinion
I would like to comment on for your
guests if I could please I've retired
from the United States Army in 1993 and
not only since that time but especially
in the past two years I've seen some
things go on in this country that are
quite disturbing to me even as little as
a year ago I was hearing allegations
about our military cruise missiles
supply being depleted and not being
replaced and here more recently I've
heard some more discussion about our
armed forces being at an all-time low
readiness level and when I combine that
with all the other comments of things I
hear about China's emerging as a threat
I'm just greatly disturbed about it and
I can't help but wonder if a very
complacent America has not been just
totally betrayed by our own leadership
and set up for a major fall and I'm
quite concerned about that and I'd like
your comment yes thank you thank you sir
we probably served at the same time
because I left the Marines in 93 also I
lived through the hollow years of the
Carter Administration I flew in those
years it was pretty bad it's ten times
worse right now the American military
you're exactly right sir it's been
reported over and over again the
divisions are c4 which means they're not
ready things are breaking down the
supply line doesn't have the supplies
necessary to sustain combat the cruise
missile inventory has been totally
depleted we our our curve is going down
dramatically while the People's Republic
of China curve is going up they haven't
crossed yet but it's getting close and
that's the problem those trends both
have to be reversed that's where the
issue of the presidential campaign is
paramount
please look at what the candidates say
again I'll go back I think governor Bush
gave one of the most magnificent
speeches on plussing up the military
John McCain will address that the
Republican side of the aisle is talking
about it I haven't seen the signals yet
from the Democrat side at this point and
very bluntly I'm gonna be very political
in this statement I think if Al Gore's
elected president is going to be Clinton
three well you've got pictures of Al
Gore with the infamous toast with the
champagne exactly but one would not have
to be a Harvard scholar to figure out
exactly where he stands on this yeah we
that's right in fact the thing we found
in our research I've never seen this
before and I've worked on both the House
and Senate in the executive department
when the economy's Chinese government
sells the truths of the cruise missiles
for example you use your callers
analysis or poison gas factories to take
another one out of the air to Iran Iraq
Syria Libya or North Korea there's must
be sanctioned we have a law in the books
that says you can't do that that law is
called the gore McCain Act never the man
is running from his own legislation
amazing Tommy thank you for your service
to our country I so appreciate it as do
millions of other Americans and I want
to give you a copy of red dragon rising
and I thank you let me go to Austin
Texas now Robert joins us i Robert hey
how you doing I'm fine thank you well
that that delay sounds like it's a
two-minute delay hone there must have
had a bad call I'll try to be nice thank
you anyway for your guest being a ex-us
nav
[Music]
I have the problem and I'm gonna be like
the devil's advocate I want to know why
they think that China would risk an
all-out war when we know and they know
that we've got the most massive amount
of nuclear subs that can wipe out their
country in a matter of moments so I'd
like to just get their their response on
why they think that China's even a
threat I don't see them as doing
anything to provoke the United States
into war because we would annihilate
them and they would be finished and I
see them only greedy to make money and
hang on there so I'll hang up and I
don't need a copy of that book I've got
enough rating to do right Robert thank
you gentlemen
well it's very simple the colors right
where it kind of would not provoke a
global thermonuclear war he's exactly
right on that what China will do is
basically try and get us to Blanc to
hold us and deterrence to keep us out of
the Pacific it's very simple if we
hesitate within 72 hours they could lose
Taiwan it has nothing to do whatsoever
with China provoking United States they
see Taiwan as theirs so consequently all
I have to do is put a through the silver
money out and say that's a strategic
asset don't you dare think it this the
fleet backs off a little bit Congress is
out of session they use information
warfare they Faraj fire those missiles
to wipe out the Taiwanese defenses and
basically that little war is over once
we blink and it's a conventional war and
maybe very few people be killed in the
process
relatively speaking any deaths are
horrible but then all bets are off in
the Pacific they could bet on the on
that issue that the president ID States
as commander-in-chief and I said of the
National Command Authority would not
race to the aid of a democratic Ally
that we've been tied to for 50 years and
that is the game going on right now in
my opinion again forgive me for the
primary aspect of this question but I
think it's important again to people who
are not into geopolitics why does China
want Taiwan they believe they own it
they when you look at a map of the old
ancient peoples of China these Empire
tell what happens to be part of it it's
part of the old civil war that
Oh didn't end but it kind of separated
us literally in 1949 and if you look at
the history of the People's Republic of
China and this is where I'll go right to
the heart of your caller he asked why
would they provoke anything well let's
look at it objectively they conquered
Tibet one of those six Tibetans are
killed they send their volunteers in
800,000 in South Korea and they lose a
lot of them thank God to the US Marine
Corps they go ahead and spring up and
help Vietnam and the Vietnam deal and
then they turn over at 79 in Nevada V 't
nam they invade India and 62 the Indians
fight to the last man fixed bayonets and
all die why does People's Republic of
China who have really no country in the
world would attack China really you look
at objectively unprovoked we wouldn't do
it no country would why are they doing
this massive military buildup sir we're
not pontificating it's not our opinion
on what China's going to do we're
telling in our Bork well-sourced what
they're saying they're going to do
that's the issue here it's not a logic
point to debate they're saying it we're
not we believe them I'd like to add
something else that goes back to the ten
on one question and that is at Tiananmen
Square at the massacre the Chinese army
saved the Communist Party basically from
the people and so the Communist Party
then starts giving them money giving
them new weapons and giving them a
mission and that happens to be the
invasion the conquest of Taiwan let me
take a break one last break eight
hundred three four three nine two eight
two that's our number every line is lit
when you hear me say goodbye try to get
online but here's here's Animorph more
important number one eight eight eight
two one nine four seven four seven
that's the number for Regnery say that
you heard Ed Timberlake and Bill triplet
I'm Janet partials America asked for red
dragon rising and they'll take 20% off
eighty eight eight two one nine four
seven four seven we'll be right
I'm only only getting warmed up yeah
that's what I was gonna say my word you
just take them at their word that was an
excellent answer you're not gonna for a
fighter simply reporting what they're
saying that's exactly and and we are
there again fine we are their enemy
they're saying it and they're practicing
we don't say and you know what we need
to do we need to refocus on their
lexicon they use the word hegemony hello
go look it up what does it mean and we
are being complicit in providing them
hegemony that's the biggest price
they're in charge that that's we are the
power we are the central core of power
and America you would be the biggest
encumbrance to that people look to us
all over the world you know in the
Middle East its Israel and and those
Arab states like wait and so forth right
want to be definitely democratic space
exactly and the erupts and so forth I
mean why do you why do so many people
try to come to the United States
illegally because we are the beacon
we're the hope and when this kind of
thing happens all it does is is
shattered can you imagine Jimmy Carter
sitting back yes in the Oval Office with
a man who has the blood of Chinese
children on his hands all the way to his
elbows mrs. Ronald Reagan or Truman yeah
and I probably should be asking this
question on the air but I'll ask it off
air did they buy the election I mean
that's the 64 million dollar session is
yeah pretty much so there's nobody broke
early no he came early yeah yeah and
that's what did it that's exactly it was
the brains of Dick Morris who was really
brilliant strategist in that area go
early advertise where the Republicans
aren't looking the national media
markets didn't pick it up and by that
point Clinton's negatives were driven
down positive driven up and everybody
came to watch the saying what's
happening out there in there folks all
trust us we know what we're doing and it
was all the early money exactly and even
in 92 don't forget the little MOC
right yes the reality is basically
getting the most money yes we put the
lemmas een ride in your there and
somebody throughout three years later
they reported month ago so yeah right
you had that three years ago it's kind
of fun to what to watch people you know
confirm your the right confirm part do
you realize how many interviews we've
done together where you said it in the
book and that all of a sudden the press
report comes they've been substantiating
since the book came out there's another
one we don't want the endgame to be we
want to stop right at that endgame
that's right we would like a word yes if
you know about it you can stop it that's
you see that's it
and I think part of that means people
that I believe that the American public
had held hostage because information
gets withheld from them yeah you give
them information and you were right on
when you said it's from the bottom up be
being astute voter find out where the
candidates stand put the people in
office who won't repeat this kind of
history again yeah and Republican I
don't care I don't have any that's
exactly right at my own account that's
exactly right I care more about my
country thank you very much and it's
gonna last longer than any party
[Music]
red dragon rising that's the name of the
new books at the Timberlake and Bill
Triplett have authored published by
Regnery it in details communist China's
military threat to America boy this hour
has gone by so quickly kara let me bring
you in on this thanks so much for
joining us okay I could and I have a son
who's an active Navy and I am concerned
over this issue he's not on a ship at
the moment so it could be at any time
and I wondered how long that it would be
before they thought that China would be
foolish enough to make some kind of an
attack and how long would it take if we
started now to build up our depleted
forces before we be ready to take the
Chinese Orange
well your husband should be commended
for being in the Navy I graduate the
Naval Academy and flew in the Marines we
should start right now on a mobilization
modernization plan the military is
hollow we have to turn it around I'm
sure your husband comes home very
frustrated as times on the way the
trends he's seen it's it's pretty bad
the young troops on food stamps horrible
as far as once we announced that that's
the beginning of the turnaround
it's called deterrence when you start to
build up your military the Chinese
government think maybe we're serious and
that stops it it's not provocation for
us to become strong and face them down
they will respect that there's a
previous caller they are rational actors
in a lot of ways the problem we have
though is that there's this unique thing
about Taiwan and they think they own it
and in a way they're very much afraid
because they're hollow they're
paper-thin they're afraid of their own
people and Taiwan is a visible example
off the coast of a democracy and by the
way 22 million people in Taiwan fifth
largest economy in Asia so the People's
Republic of China have a serious dilemma
here in which there is an example of how
they could lose all their power my big
fear is that the president States has
sent a signal that all your listeners
Janet wouldn't believe the signal is
very simple we're indecisive we're weak
we'll give it up I really don't think if
the Congress was called in or the
American people knew what the issues
were
I think we'd stand tall but the message
isn't getting out there right now and
that's the debate we need to have
absolutely that's certainly an issue and
that's the question of why is why is it
not being reported that Taiwan is being
threatened with missiles I think it
ought to be on all of the television
stations and I think Mother's newspapers
besides the Washington Times I mean
there's no question that bill Kurtz is
the best but you know I think it needs
to go out wider
amen to that gentlemen you are very much
instrumental in making it go out there
wider I can't thank you enough you could
have written about all kinds of things
writing about this is not the easiest in
the world and as you were saying this is
not necessarily how you want the story
to end this is a wake-up call for
America to be resolved in the
we didn't get into the drugs and thugs
part of this will you come back again
soon we've hardly scratched the surface
on this lawyer gentlemen thank you so
much Carol we're gonna give you a copy
of the book as well it's called red
dragon rising communist China's military
threat to America if you care about
America then put your other reading
aside and read this now because we the
people can make a difference let's do it
we'll see you next time
you have a okay here's how drugs and
thugs works
here's Burma she's one of the nastiest
places here okay the drugs go this way
drugs go this way this is the u.s. there
okay
all right here comes the dollars right
here and they're there they're broke
okay
then then the dollars go up to a Chinese
company called poly technology's
disgusted - poly and guns go down to
suppress the Burmese people okay and
then the the chairman of the board
chairman where does he he's over here
he's in this little house okay this
little house and it happens to be white
okay
and he's got a cup of coffee watching
this is 50k here okay and somehow or
another this whole issue this whole
issue doesn't and the guns going back by
the way is the tenth car lose operation
Oh oh dear when you look at the end
notes we make it clear that we have full
sympathy with the real ruler Burma until
she Sookie and Nobel Prize recipient
even died and she wouldn't leave the
country I remember back in yeah turn our
courage right anyway this is the
sequence and nothing somehow happens
here well that forget me for something
like the common man again but if we've
got this if you can substantiate this
have we grown weary of trying to get
oversight hearings on the hill on this
well they do it but unfortunately the
Justice Department isn't prosecute see
and that's where we're getting
stonewalled isn't it does it justice
because the Congress can't prosecute
everybody is confused that's exactly
that's right only only they can turn
around and say this is how they lied to
us
do something here's another one for next
time this is Gore McCain if that was
unbelievable when you brought that up
that was a great point okay here's
here's the manufacturer
okay this is the manufacturer of the of
the missiles and here's the broker
okay the manufacturer is our friend
Lieutenant Colonel ooh
and here's the 300 K that goes to the
DNC by the way we report on counter Chun
they report that John fallow knew she
was a lieutenant colonel we asked from
the hill they didn't tell us that
oh my word okay and here's here's the
broker all right here's the broker and
this is the coffee again same guy okay
these two together the broker and so
forth they sell hundreds hundreds of
cruise missiles mm-hmm missiles and we
have something in the order of ten to
thirteen thousand troops men women you
know whatever in the Gulf that were
within range of these stuffs okay so and
nothing and in in I've been on the hill
16 years I've never seen an instance
where a man who or woman who had a piece
of legislation that was theirs had their
name on it didn't want it and you see
what happened is it doesn't get enforced
and I'll be honest with you senator Gor
then center core Senator McCain and
that's his staff guy McCain staff guy
and I wrote the bill that's why I'm so
yes it was going to be enforced it
doesn't get enforced and the Navy gets
so angry they come on the back channel
and they come and see us okay and
Admiral Scott red gave gate when he was
in charge in the Middle East gave two
interviews to Gertz in which he
complained about this okay and even cut
Jeopardy News career your whistleblower
you're gone this is this is this is you
know endangering the US Navy
exactly exactly what I was thinking wife
make somebody's wife these days okay
I mean nephew if Congress can't
rightfully prosecute because of the
separation of powers we've got this
legislation on the book how do we put
teeth in it then if it's there you know
what we really need I think what we
really need is some oversight hearings
by Duncan Hunter and Weldon because
they're both subcommittee chairmen it's
my house and if they hold it here a
hearing on the on the military aspects
of this I'm still working in the sense
so I can't testify right but he can
testify but you know we really need to
have some extensive hearings on this
whole business and and I just don't
understand why the problem is I do
understand why the war won't go out of
his way to to enforce his own
legislation I mean that's crazy I mean
it all ends up you see the manufacturer
and the broker both have a money
relationship with the White House that's
amazing
direct money cash our checks actor oh
yeah in the White House it was
documented I mean Johnny Chong we
believe is an honest man and he made a
mistake but you know he's right in the
door you go in the rep here this lady is
malleus Bible arms dealer and she was
the rep for the manufacturer and this
guy who was the chairman of the board
it's the guy who women went into the
coffee what we're dealing with
no kidding yeah no kidding you talk
about beating your head against a brick
wall
well if justice is stymied because the
king's man is the AG right then what we
have to do is work with what we have on
the books and notice it's there so that
has to have life breathe back then do it
for make that come back and the play for
applications sake I great and and and
and if you make it a national campaign
in two agree yes and you just hold it
right in camera is it defense declining
yes or no if it is we can do that if no
okay you're a record exactly you know
it's China threat yes or no if no fine
exists your statement exam
yes what are you gonna do now somebody
had this as a question and I wanted to
ask it but I didn't get to the question
and that was let's say China does make
an aggressive move say it decides to say
we're taking China I mean I found this
point the times very interesting where
the Defense report says that China's
growing short-range missile force is a
potent weapon that can be used to either
a for combat or as a strategic weapon to
influence relations with China in other
words Damocles sword you hang it over
time let me say this it was that what
we've got in fact that can also to keep
us out of this exactly so so would they
ever take the next step and co-op I mean
if they're going to build all of this
stuff it isn't just all happen to puff
and blow your house down but I'll hit
that red button but but they don't spend
a billion dollars each one of these
things is about a billion dollars when
you count the ship and the missiles okay
is about a billion dollars you don't
spend a billion dollars to rolled sea
mines off the stern exactly exactly and
and we really believe that they get in
there fast we may not get there in time
I guess you got to eat your next segment
everybody thank you
[Music]
I admit sticks in my craw because Leon
Firth if you go into your yellow book
you'll find him in the White House who's
the national security guy for for Leon
and I and 20 courts man who was McCain
sky at the time we drafted this thing we
intended to protect America thank you no
that's all right that I wanted you to
finish your thought we're playing a tape
on this hour so will you come back again
soon and do this of course because we
have hardly you know why I have yes no
kidding life is it's tough time I've
about every 48 hours something horrible
breaks of course the dilemma you have is
that right now they know the endgame
they know our top secret stuff Chris
Coxon and and guy named Porter Goss
showing the house that said that they
also have bought all the Russian
top-secret stuff that the highest the
Serbian an adventurer they sent a
purchasing in where ten billion dollars
and bought all Russian radio frequency
weapons also they're very good at that
exactly great physicist so Beijing knows
the sum total most
high-tech stuff hi top-secret stuff they
can't get from here to there though on
some of the manufacturing aspects of it
they won't go so far so so do they upset
the applecart with this president who's
let all those guard down exactly or do
they go ahead while this president may
blink and give them Taiwan they have a
dilemma
they've got exactly do ya now let me ask
you speaking of dilemmas for the United
States we get up as principal people and
we say you fight for a democracy you
don't allow it to be subsumed by a
communist country we have to be able to
put feet to that we can't just make it
and look like how lamentable thing in
the world so let's say they do one
airstrike they just want to show us how
strong their do we sit back do we wait I
mean are we willing to put our our feet
where our mouth is on this I hope so but
the American people have to understand
this because it's gonna be it could be
buddies Oh exactly and that's this is no
Gulf War hundred hours later the other
thing is frankly they need to do what we
did to the Iraqis and that is you know
have the Congress say to people like me
and my colleagues start typing
legislation you know no product
manufactured mind grown whatever shall
be permitted into the customs territory
of the United States after midnight on
the data you know actually it would be
very interesting with it because we
would hoist them on their own paternity
trade that got us to sell away principle
so let's take trade this guy this guy
and other and the other guys they all
have secret investments in the United
States that I can't share with you well
know where they are and so you
confiscate oh yeah we can play our golf
I mean we can't so that would be the
best weapon we would have actually would
you sure sure wow that's amazing yeah so
so we have a lot of but the problem is
we can't guy that's exactly right and is
it at all just fate that we have these
kinds of screening headlines or when we
know that we're now in an election cycle
I mean quite frankly voluble as a
country in my but a lot of it as
chickens coming home to roost yes you
know basically what if when you deal
with the Clinton administration we have
these endless Congress
all the time are we dealing with
corruption or incompetence of some
horrible joint venture - that's a lot of
stuff is coming back I mean for example
that the silver mini has been deal has
been in the works since 96 and certain
other things for example you look at
Kurtz's piece you'll see it says the
construction is almost completed yes now
okay we found - okay how many others are
completed we haven't found yet that's
right that's right the whole series of
family series type model series of a
Chinese missile on the sea of 25 they
lost it it was on the books right until
four minutes later when they said oh by
the way we do built it and it's very
good exactly yeah and didn't you love
the braggadocio aspect of taking once at
the CSS and dragging it down on the 50th
anniversary the Communists we're pretty
harsh we say why don't we name call but
in one area I believed them when they
said their news force oh I see I believe
that I believe that that should be taken
literally yeah I do too I believe then
when they start writing this stuff and
and teaching it different phd's
information warfare for their military
officers weren't even up for that much
jeez Louise well I think that's why we
have to do a lot of this in this
election cycle because then again I
don't care if it's a Republican or
Democrat just take good care of my
country I want to be our guy
that's our lady that's - yeah that's
right that's exactly have some fun
sometime invite to Nancy Pelosi to talk
about this kind of effect yeah isn't
that interesting
yeah that's why she's very join forces
across the oh yeah well I think you've
been right you bet she is and she came
out strong on that did you see well I
thought that was mostly yeah sometimes
invite her in you know ask her to come
and talk about about China and that's a
great idea and the PLA that's a great
idea
the cold and she's very good she and my
boss mr. Solomon used to all the time go
to the floor boy they just they just
they want me to get each other but
they'd be together go after oh yeah the
free trade aspect of this exactly you
know I mean that's bull sizing I'll tell
ya Epps will see that goes back again to
the coalition's that we've talked about
darling said that it really isn't it
isn't about party division from my
vantage point it's about principle
versus profit division and that doesn't
no party affiliation anymore well I tell
you what you guys are just a tremendous
asset to our country thank you thank you
very much
what is to like you for pumping us well
did you did you like the quote that you
had in today's Washington Times just
well I mean timing is excellent can I
keep this yeah I mean obviously we were
working with Bill and you know a
Pentagon official and we call ourselves
the blue team and because they're the
red team and you'll see if you go
through and say who is talking there's a
Pentagon official he's a blue team guy
and in fact he and I met at the temple a
restaurant oh isn't that interesting
oh my word it's better than the Tom
Clancy novel do you like the kool-aid
come back we'll do this again thank you
very much thank you sir thank you
red dragon rising is published by
Regnery